for several weeks now Kanye West has
been spewing anti-semitic hate speech on
social media platforms radio and TV
including tweeting that he was going to
go Defcon 3 on Jewish people he's also
appeared on a popular podcast over here
repeating tired old tropes about Jewish
people controlling business and money to
the exclusion of others
anti-semitic hate crimes are already on
the rise in America and many people fear
that Kanye West's statements and his
behavior may have emboldened Nazi groups
for example there was a protest here in
Los Angeles over the weekend where a
group of Nazi demonstrators gathered on
a Motorway bridge and hung banners over
one of which said Kanye West is right
about Jewish people so you can imagine a
huge amount of concern about what's
happening
celebrities though have United in
condemnation of Kanye West his ex-wife
Kim Kardashian saying this rhetoric this
hateful rhetoric against Jewish people
must be constantly called out almost all
of the businesses and sponsors
associated with Kanye West have now
dropped him he's also been dropped by
his talent agency Adidas were among the
last remaining businesses that were
standing by him but under enormous
pressure they have now terminated their
partnership to Adidas say it's cost them
almost 250 million dollars Financial
experts say it could have cost Kanye
West more than a billion dollars
so with this anti-semitic hate speech
he's not only taken a sledgehammer to
his reputation but his fortunes too and
what happens next is anybody's guess but
Kanye West may find it very hard to
recover his previous standing in
Hollywood